Não me sinto ansiosa, na verdade, nem sei.
Eu acho que a ansiedade que tenho é... Nem sei bem se a sinto.
Eu acho que é uma coisa que se manifesta de outra forma.
Há dois ou três dias tenho um tico nervoso no olho, mas agora até parou.
Portanto, estou só a respirar fundo e tentar estar-me tranquila.
Não quero estressar com nada.
já uns dias tem sido aquilo que tenho feito por exemplo ontem despechei tarde e tudo mais a hora que for porque também não tenho como só tinha a cirurgia à tarde fazer as coisas com calma com sensibilidade já coisas que não vale a pena nós também estarmos a a estressar se não chegar uma hora antes chego à hora vai acontecer vai correr bem
E acho que é importante isso, manter-me serena.
E, portanto, sinto-me bem.
Sinto um bocadinho de fome.
Um bocadinho de sede.
Mas... Se isto vai ser rápido, acho que não vai sentir.
Estou muito otimista.
Em relação àquilo que vai acontecer.
E, pronto, espero que... Estou com uma energia positiva em relação àquilo... Mesmo o pós-operatório.
Não só o operatório, mas no pós.
vou ser uma boa paciente, vou fazer tudo o que me disserem e vai correr bem e vou me livrar disto.
Eu não sou assim muito de ficar nervosa, ansiosa, porque eu acho que no fundo não serve nada.
Acho que também uma das coisas que me ajudou muito foi, com isso a minha mãe teve quatro vezes cancro.
E às vezes eu acho que as pessoas sofrem muito antes de terem até uma confirmação.
Portanto, eu acho que aprendi a ser otimista, a olhar mais para o futuro, de pensar de uma forma positiva sobre o futuro, e aquilo que vier de mal, a gente resolve na altura.
Portanto, não vale para nem sofrer agora, se uma coisa pode nem acontecer, eventualmente.
E pronto, mas às vezes eu ia a uma consulta e quando saía, saía muito fragilizada, porque era uma coisa que eu não escolhi, que não...
Mas, pronto, depois também lembrava o estado em que a minha mãe viveu, teve quatro meses de cancro, como disse, mas ficou muito limitada.
Já está com demência, também acho que afetou muito também os tratamentos todos que teve que fazer.
Então, ela sempre teve vários problemas de saúde e pronto, enfim.
Mas, contrariamente, acho que até estou mais serena até do que os dias que se deu, que às vezes, de repente, sim.
Quando alguém olhava para mim e ficava aflito porque sabia, eu também vinha assim um bocadinho abaixo, mas ficava assim sensibilizada, de pensar, nem estou a ver onde é que estou metida, mas sou eu, não é?
Portanto, isto é sobre mim.
E eu nem estou a ver.
Mas é isso.
Mas não.
A resposta é a mesma.
Sim, bem.
Pronto.